they answered the call to serve their
country
but for many that service was cut
tragically
short 96 people were on board the c-130
aircraft
when it crashed in hollow more than 80
of them were newly trained
soldiers about to report for their tour
of duty
in one of the most militarized areas in
the southern philippines
the aircraft landed on sunday afternoon
but as this video show it crashed
seconds later
[Music]
villagers raced to the scene and helped
to pull survivors from the burning
wreckage
more than 50 people died and 40 others
were injured
making it one of the worst military
accidents in recent times
we are determined to find out what
really transpired
according to available information the
aircraft followed the specified protocol
approach speed the landing spot
it followed all those protocol the
military says
the pilots were very experienced and
well-rated
and the aircraft still had 11 000 flying
hours left
before it would have been retired so
what caused the plane to overshoot the
runway remains for now a mystery
a select group of seasoned pilots will
help investigators
determine the cause the philippine
military had four c-130s at its disposal
before the crash
two of these are undergoing repairs
abroad while the remaining one in manila
has been grounded pending further
investigation
but the process of identifying all those
who died
may take a few days the airstrip in halo
is relatively small compared to other
domestic runways
but c-130s have safely landed here for
decades
and foul play has been ruled out it has
been a trying time for the philippine
military
there have been nine recorded crashes in
the last year
many of them fatal but it appears
this is a country that doesn't have time
to grieve
before being hit with another disaster
jamal linda al jazeera manila